hi i'm kristen bell i'm here with
buzzfeed and i am going to rank my
characters
okay between sarah marshall or beth from
when in rome i think sarah marshall was
a little more interesting so i'm gonna
go sarah marshall anna from frozen or
nicki from burlesque anna was way nicer
i gotta go anna all the way okay cynthia
from couples retreat was that my name
and couples retreat cynthia that's news
to me or laura newton from spartan oh i
like laura newton because she was a
tough cookie i didn't dislike cynthia i
just don't remember her very well marnie
from you again or kiki from bad moms
i think kiki between veronica mars or l
bishop from heroes i mean l does have
super powers but veronica's like my
heart and soul so i gotta go veronica
eleanor shellstrop from the good place
or ooda banked from party down oh no i
loved them both oh no that's a toughy i
would have to go with eleanor because i
spent more time with her fell in love
with her more okay gossip girl or
jeannie vanderhuven on house of lies
that's tough but i think it's genie for
me okay we're getting down to the
nitty-gritty now anna from the woman in
the house or ingrid de forest from parks
and rec
shoot i loved ingrid too but i'm doing
press for the woman in the house across
the street from the girl in the window
now on netflix so i'm gonna go with anna
between sarah marshall and anna from
frozen that's brutal but i'm gonna go
with anna laura newton from spartan and
kiki from bad moms i'm gonna go kiki
between veronica mars and eleanor
shellstrop guys this really is kill your
darlings it's like choosing a favorite
kid which i obviously have but i could
never write down or say on television uh
i gotta go veronica mars between genie
vanderhooven and anna from the woman in
the house i'm gonna go anna between anna
from frozen and kiki from bad moms no
contest it's anna veronica mars and anna
from the woman in the house i gotta go
be mars i mean i love
loved the character i just played but
veronica mars now this this has always
been something i've struggled with
because these are the yin and yang of my
personality is it anna from frozen or
veronica mars i don't know how to do
this guys
ana mars can i say that i'm gonna write
it down moment of truth
it's anna from frozen i think that's my
favorite character of all time please
check out my new show the woman in the
house across the street from the girl in
the window now on netflix woo that was
tough i'm sweating